it's about freedom ultimately whether
you want to live in a society that
embraces innovation and free speech and
freedom or not and I'm certainly glad to
live in a country that does that
the New York State Department of
Financial Services just concluded a
two-day fact-finding hearing on how to
regulate Bitcoin and other virtual
crypto currencies a big questions on the
table were should New York State have a
role in overseeing the use of virtual
currencies or do existing federal
regulations suffice
right now the regulation of virtual
currency industry is still akin to a
virtual Wild West that lack of
regulation however is simply not tenable
for the long term let's just understand
what we're trying to do with Bitcoin
we're trying to create a world where
transactions can move globally for free
okay and making these companies hire you
know some outsource compliance firm is
is a bad idea for regulators the biggest
concern is that Bitcoin will be used to
facilitate narco trafficking and other
illegal activities one day before the
hearing started Charlie Shrem a major
figure in the Bitcoin community was
arrested on charges of using
cryptocurrency to launder money the
Winklevoss brothers who appeared at the
hearings were major investors in trance
firm legal action that we saw yesterday
underscores how critically important it
is that we put in place guardrails for
this industry to help root out money
laundering and other misconduct it seems
like the system is working law
enforcement did a fantastic job using
existing regulations and their capacity
and their capabilities to find out the
people behind it and they shut it down
are you saying though that it couldn't
happen again today my point is that you
know you're asking how can how can we
control this and my answer is it appears
to have been controlled at a later
session to top law enforcement officials
directly involved in these money
laundering cases express the opposite
view I don't think the fact that we have
made significant cases and arrests in
this arena means that it's all under
control it's not yes there have been
significant cases but these cases like
Silk Road and Liberty Reserve there were
hundreds of people engaged in criminal
conduct dealing with these entities and
dealing in virtual currencies they have
not all been arrested what sorts of
rules are needed to help combat money
laundering that don't already exist on
the federal level
participants offered few specifics
overall Bitcoin investors expressed
hopes that new regulations will be
written broadly enough that they don't
halt innovation or drive the industry
abroad over time the regulators are
gonna have to come up with a way to
treat Bitcoin that is balanced and
thoughtful but also recognize that this
is a global phenomena the companies are
gonna get created jobs gonna get
creative innovations gonna happen we've
got to figure out a way to do it in a
balanced way so that it happens here in
the US and hopefully here in New York
they coined allows to do op allistic
incumbents it challenges them and I
think that's very healthy I think that's
very American I think that's what we
should all be striving for